greetings my name is Gordon feller and
the director of ribbon innovation at
cisco systems in Silicon Valley I mean
here in Abu Dhabi of World Economic
Forum Global Agenda councils and the
council I'm with is urban urbanization
and infrastructure and our new models
debate since this is our first day
together as focused on new models for an
infrastructure that are sustainable that
are connected that are smart and that
are economically productive particularly
that supports Social Development
positive social development so we're
talking about success factors what are
the criteria that we would want to
choose before we present to the rest of
the world economic forum the best
practices and success stories of
sustainable and connected and smart
urban infrastructure so one of those
elements of the new model will be public
private partnership it's not simply an
initiative of government or industry but
it's a combination of the resources and
wisdom of both another is that there's
deep public participation third is that
there's a environmental impact which is
positive impact where resources are
scarce and therefore preserved and
conserved so those are some of the
criteria that we're talking about and
since I'm with Cisco of course we're
talking about the underlying digital
platform the network that essentially
provides the capacity for a city to
develop smart and connected
infrastructure so that's a bit of a
snapshot of what we're doing and now I'm
going to run off to the council meeting
good to meet you